Traduttore: Alberto Pagani
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera.
Nel mio paese c'è una strada
che si chiama
Via della Barbiera.
Io un giorno ho chiesto il perché
del nome di questa strada
e da lì è venuta la storia
che adesso vi racconto.
La storia di un viaggio.
Un tempo, a viaggiare, erano gli uomini
ma anche una ragazzetta
partì dai monti,
sola.
La guerra non era ancora cominciata
e l'inverno era appena finito.
La mattina che se ne andò
staccò lo specchio da sopra l'acquaio,
prese il rosario dal capo del letto
e si mise in tasca
gli orecchini di corallo.
E poi via, senza salutare nessuno.
Sentì un nodo alla gola
mentre passava la soglia di casa.
Lo sentì anche a scendere le scale,
e poi attraversò l'aia
e non sentì più nulla.
S'affidò ai viottoli,
a quello che avrebbe voluto
la Santa Vergine.
Non si era mai allontanata dal casolare.
Il tetto d'ardesia, poche stanze
buie e affumicate,
il ronzio fitto delle mosche
tra il Passo delle Forbici e il Casone.
Nomi che li conosce solo la gente di lì.
Un posto da lupi, senza una piazzetta,
senza una chiesina, nulla.
Intorno i boschi e sopra il cielo.
E lei stava lì, sotto il cielo,
sotto il tetto d'ardesia.
Né bella né brutta, secca secca
con un foularino in testa
che nessuno le aveva mai visto i capelli.
Dei figli era la più grande,
i suoi eran carbonai:
una famiglia chiusa,
sembravano nati per tribolare e basta.
A sette anni, in piedi su un panchetto
perché altrimenti
non arrivava all'acquaio
faceva i piatti,
e finito di rigovernare
andava alla fonte
a prender l'acqua.
Neve, vento... toccava a lei.
Era lei che faceva il bucato al fiume,
con la lisciva nell'acqua gelata
che a volte
non sentiva neanche più le manine.
Ed era lei che di notte
veniva svegliata dalla nonna.
"Oh bimba, levatevi!
Si dice un'Ave Maria alla Madonna,
dopo ci si riaddorme.
A modino, mani giunte."
Sul comodino c'era un piatto
coperto con la carta gialla.
E un coltello.
Pregavano.
E poi la vecchia prendeva il piatto,
c'era una fetta di pane, del burro,
e un trucciolino di zucchero.
Metteva il burro sul pane,
lo zucchero sopra
e siccome non aveva i denti
per masticare
con il coltello incideva
tutta la crosta intorno.
E se lo mangiavano insieme,
a pezzetti,
e la bimba si addormentava
con quel dolce dello zucchero in bocca.
Era l'unica dolcezza che le toccava.
Perché in casa sua
non erano avvezzi a certe cose
e a lei dispiaceva
di non essere mai presa sulle ginocchia.
Mai un complimento, mai un bacino.
A volte avrebbe voluto esser lei
ad andargli intorno, strusciarsi,
come in quella casa faceva solo il gatto.
Ma si accorgeva
di esser vergognosa come loro,
era venuta su così,
senza tante moine.
Con due cose da temere:
dispiacere alla Madonna
e la cinghia di suo padre.
Una mattina suo padre
rientrò bestemmiando,
aveva la mano avvolta in uno straccio.
Sanguinava.
S'era portato via le dita col pennato.
Restò a casa pochi giorni,
sembrava una bestia in gabbia.
Quel pomeriggio erano soli in casa,
lei a fare i piatti e lui seduto al tavolo.
Quando le disse di spicciarsi,
che dopo gli doveva fare la barba.
La bimba si voltò e vide
che aveva già il rasoio in mano,
e seguitò a fare i piatti, zitta.
Poi si avvicinò al babbo,
prese lo specchio da sopra l'acquaio
e glielo mise nella mano buona.
Mentre bagnava le setole
che si gonfiavano col sapone,
il babbo spiegava come fare.
Poi appoggiò la testa indietro
e il pennello coprì il viso di schiuma.
Prese il rasoio...
"Occhio bimba!
Che qui non siete a fa' le comarelle.
Questo qui taglia davvero."
Era la prima volta che teneva in mano
una cosa così da maschi.
Entrò con la lama nella schiuma,
appoggiò la lama alla carne
e lasciò andare la mano
che scivolò libera dagli zigomi al mento
lasciando sulla pelle una striscia liscia,
come una strada.
Venne tutto da sé.
Ci sono delle sapienze
che uno si porta dentro
senza neanche conoscerle.
E lei quel giorno scoprì la sua.
Alla fine il babbo, toccandosi,
faceva "Uhm... uh uh"
Segno che anche per lui era stata brava.
Non aveva ancora dodici anni
e la mandarono a servizio
in una famiglia.
Le toccarono gli stessi lavori di casa,
compresa la barba
al marito della signora.
Perché i suoi,
quando la raccomandarono,
lo dissero che aveva l'estro
per fare la barbiera.
Ci restò parecchi anni.
Il necessario per fare la barba
era in una bella scatola di latta rossa.
Il giorno che scappò
era un giorno pensato tante volte.
Scappò dopo il lavoro.
La mattina, da casa sua,
aveva portato via
lo specchio da sopra l'acquaio.
Alla signora rubò la scatola di latta.
Portò via anche un asciugamano,
una formetta di pecorino
ed era lì lì per prendere delle uova,
invece agguantò una gallina,
era già sul trespolo a dormire.
Fu questione di un attimo,
la mise nel sacco e via,
senza far chiasso.
Ma la domenica avanti
si era alzata per tempo
ed era andata a San Pellegrino
con un sasso grosso così.
San Pellegrino
rimaneva nell'altro versante
e lei cominciò a camminare tra i boschi
con il sasso in una cesta sulle spalle.
San Pellegrino è in alto,
in cima alla montagna.
È un borgo di case
su un'unica strada
e su quella strada c'è il santuario
con le spoglie di San Pellegrino.
San Pellegrino era figlio di un re
ma rinunciò alla corona,
si mise in viaggio
e da qui il nome Pellegrino.
Finché guidato da una stella
arrivò lassù sui monti
dove anche il diavolo lo seguì.
Il diavolo era così arrabbiato
con quest'uomo
perché non cedeva alle sue tentazioni,
che un giorno gli dette uno schiaffo
così forte
da farlo girare per tre volte.
E per la potenza di quello schiaffo
tutta la terra tremò
e si staccarono dei sassi dal monte.
E oggi lì, nel punto dello schiaffo,
di sassi ce n'è una distesa.
Li ha portati la gente per devozione.
Più pesante è il senso di colpa,
più grosso è il sasso.
E prima di riporlo,
per tre volte in ginocchio
si fa il giro dell'intera distesa.
La ragazza arrivò su stremata
e si mise a girare,
con i ginocchi che si sgronciolavano,
e alla fine si strinse al sasso.
"Oh San Pellegrino benedetto
perdonatemi le colpe,
aiutatemi a scappa'.
Guidatemi vo' per i monti
perché io le vie all'infori di torno casa
non le so.
E dove andrò a fini',
fatemici arriva' sana.
Abbiate misericordia di me.
Non c'ho dormito a nottate a rimuginarci,
non ne posso più di sta' qui.
Vo' ve ne siete andato di casa
e potevate esser re.
Mi capite no?
Aiutate anche mi pa' e mi ma',
loro non mi capiranno mai.
Ve lo poso qui il sasso,
datemi la forza di non ritornarci quassù.
Vi vo' bene."
Depose la pietra,
un po' di saliva sui ginocchi e via.
Con le spalle più leggere
e con l'anima pesante.
E con l'anima pesante,
il fagotto di cose rubate,
la gallina nel sacco,
quella sera prese per i viottoli
per non tornare più.
A casa sua
se ne sarebbero accorti dopo un po'.
Potevano disperarsi, maledire il destino,
ma non c'era tempo da perdere
a cercarla.
Il buio le entrava dentro
insieme ai rimorsi.
Stava stretta agguantata al rosario.
Lo ripeteva di continuo,
un'Ave Maria dopo l'altra.
Graffi, scivolate, non sentiva nulla.
Solo gli scossoni della gallina
che si dimenava nel sacco,
spaventata come lei.
Ci volle del tempo per scollettare,
arrivava di là da un monte
e ne vedeva un altro.
Si accorse che era alla piana
perché era tutto tutto tutto libero
e là in fondo... il mare.
Non l'aveva mai visto.
Se l'era immaginato tante volte
ma anche adesso che era vicina
non ci andò.
Ce n'era di cose prima
di andare a vedere il mare.
La strada divideva la piana in due:
e di qua, di là, nel mezzo,
c'erano i casolari, le galline, le mucche,
e le sembrò tutto sparpagliato.
Sui monti era più unito, era più raccolto.
Fece caso a un viottoletto lungo un fosso,
c'era un bell'albero di fico.
Sotto c'era un tronco, tagliato basso.
Gente non ce n'era,
ma le venne lo stesso di nascondersi.
Disse un'altra volta il rosario
e poi se lo mise al collo,
andò sotto il fico
e sentì che era arrivata.
Lasciò libera la gallina
che lì per lì non si mosse,
mezza stordita.
Attaccò lo specchio a un ramo del fico
e graffiando sulla scatola di latta
ci scrisse Barbiera.
E la barbiera cominciò
a rasare i maschi della piana.
Quella gente che parlava poco,
venuta dal nulla.
Cominciò a rasare contadini e marinai.
Di lei sapevano
"che ven di per in sù da monti
e l'Argene la fa dormi' nel granaio"
e basta.
Gli uomini presero l'abitudine
di trovarsi sotto il fico,
era il sabato il giorno
della barba fatta come si deve.
Dei capelli impomatati di brillantina.
Finito uno, scuoteva l'asciugamano e via,
sotto un altro.
Non sorrideva, non dava confidenza,
occhi bassi, ma aveva un tocco...
Sotto il fico imparò i discorsi dei maschi
perché mentre radeva uno
gli altri parlavano
del prezzo delle sementi,
dei viaggi verso il Brasile, l'Argentina,
per cambiare vita.
Alzavano la voce,
lei faceva finta di nulla.
Oppure parlavano
della domenica nell'aia
a ballare con l'organetto.
Le piaceva ascoltare.
Sotto il fico imparò anche
i ragionamenti dei marinai.
I mariai erano diversi dagli altri uomini.
Avevano visto così tanto mondo,
mamma mia.
Quando lo raccontavano
sembrava inventato.
E poi fischiavano sempre.
Tutti gli uomini fischiettavano,
li vedevi arrivare sulle biciclette
e sembravano degli usignoli.
Ma i marinai di più.
Per i marinai, il fischio
era proprio un modo per comunicare.
C'era una fischiata
che era dei marinai versiliesi,
solo di quelli.
E se gli capitava di trovarsi
in un porto lontano
dove non conoscevano la lingua
e fischiavano in quel modo lì,
se c'era un altro versiliese
col fischio si trovavano.
Poi i marinai avevano
anche un altro odore.
Perché a forza di stare accostata
ai maschi
aveva imparato l'odore
della pelle dei maschi
e li aveva catalogati nella sua mente.
I marinai avevano catrame e salmastro,
non si sentiva altro.
Soldi non ne vedeva,
però le portavano il pane,
la verdura, l'uva.
Una volta, proprio un marinaio,
le portò un romanzo,
un librone di tela.
Lei non era spedita a leggere,
per capire una frase
la doveva ripetere tante volte
a voce alta.
Poi però s'appassionò,
entrò nella storia
e lo lesse sei o sette volte il libro.
Avrebbe voluto leggerne altri
ma non ci fu modo.
Accadde una mattina,
arrivò vociando un gruppo di spose
e non c'era nessuno
a quell'ora per la barba.
"Oh sudicia, te ne devi anda' di qui
hai inteso?
Tanto gli omini con te
non ce lo fanno l'amore.
Con te ci volino gode' e basta.
Schifosa!"
La spinsero, e la fecero cadere.
E lei voleva parlare, spiegarsi,
ma le parole le si bloccavano nella gola.
Quelle bocche spalancate, senza grazia,
che sembrava che se la mangiassero
le ricordavano la colpa vera:
l'unico rimorso,
essere scappata di casa
e non essersene pentita,
mai.
Fu l'Argeni a farle smettere,
sentì il baccano e arrivò di corsa.
"Aria! Via! Sciolare!
Ci penso io a lei.
Ricordatevi che questa ragazza
non ha fatto nulla di male."
E restò con il braccio teso
sinché non si furono allontanate.
La domenica dopo
la videro con Cesarino,
cambiati.
Erano andati dal prete.
Fu lei a dirgli del Brasile.
Aveva sentito di gente
partita con nulla
che laggiù si era fatta una posizione.
Si imbarcarono a dicembre,
lei per l'occasione
si mise gli orecchini di corallo,
tolse la pezzola dai capelli,
aveva una bella treccia dietro,
stava bene.
Nel mio paese, a Forte dei Marmi,
c'è una strada che si chiama
Via della Barbiera.
Le origini del nome
di questa strada sono vaghe.
Qualcuno dice che viene da barriera
perché è una strada
vicina al confine fra due comuni.
Qualcuno dice che viene da Barberi,
un cognome tipico della zona.
Ma i più sostengono
che in quella strada,
quand'era ancora un viottolo,
c'era una donna
che faceva la barba sotto il fico.
(Applausi)
Grazie